Brenna's like you're shooting at me
he'll be fine like you don't want me to
do that come on
just do it so let's pretend that skull
is wrens head and let's see what would
have happened had I not talked him out
of this
there we go rig works functional after
the success of GoPro on an arrow I want
to do a follow-up video because I really
want to do a video where we actually do
the perspective of an arrow shot over a
battle the GoPro in an arrow it just it
doesn't shoot far enough for us to
actually get that effect of an area like
arcing over a battlefield come along
with us as we put a GoPro in a cannon so
this is the master blaster this is an
air cannon that we've built so we used
to actually shoot gasoline out of it
making giant fire balls so here's what
I'm thinking it's just big enough to fit
in here the very first thing I do is
actually develop a projectile for this
now same had some ideas let's go see
what he's up to is modeling something in
3d for 3d printing so we're gonna
basically create a custom 3d printed
housing for the GoPro to fit inside this
is a 7-hour print so all those little
things here are the supports we're gonna
cut them off to reveal the full form
underneath it I'm hoping it works
because probability is not my favorite I
would have designed it very differently
any time you have a sharp corner that's
what's called a stress concentration if
you ever have a failure it's gonna
happen exactly where like a 90 degree
sharp corners I actually predict that it
will break up on impact if it's very
snugly in there oh alright someone go
down there and we throw it I honestly
don't think this tale is gonna do
anything for aerodynamics having this on
here does help it if you're just
throwing a GoPro and hoping that the
GoPro stays perfectly facing you yeah
Neko has no ham and it's broken and it's
broken there we go
oh hey it broken the exact spot I
thought it would right angle man you
really put a lot of effort into catching
it though the general idea is actually
pretty solid if we're to do this
differently instead of just like a hard
joint we have like sort of like an
hourglass shape going down and then
going back out so it's just one smooth
line to the end of the tail here I mean
honestly you turn up pretty well I think
it's gonna work pretty well actually
oh my god I have no idea if this is
actually gonna work though once it flies
out of a cannon when you put anything in
that cannon it flies out really it
doesn't matter what you put in there so
snug that's not gonna come out but hey
if it's just lightly bigger hole so time
against the worst baby tonight guys I'm
really excited for this mm-hmm I'm like
really excited for this right now no one
has any idea how far it's gonna go two
options one aim real high and hope that
it doesn't go far or two aim low
assuming it could go any distance well
want to shoot at a 45-degree angle to
get the maximum range these things can
go incredibly far though we'll see we'll
see well there's no
[Applause]
let's do this I'm nervous man
don't be nervous be excited
three-two-one
survived Amin dude that went way further
than I thought it was like a frickin
missile oh I can't we do a straight-up
shot oh dude all right I'm gonna shoot
this straight up well slightly forward
so here like that listen let's put this
in there before you go down well three
two one
oh crap I don't even know our wet oh I
see it baby
Oh baby I'm so high
[Applause]
cut off halfway through Selina we broke
the governor we have another we're gonna
go back out tomorrow to fire that one
but in the meantime it gave me a great
opportunity to do the mat and we knew
from google maps that that first arrow
went 440 feet across the field and from
looking at the footage we knew was in
the air for exactly 4.3 seconds so this
thing here left that cannon at 84 miles
an hour to fly 440 feet for the second
shot the one that actually killed the
GoPro it was in the air for 7.8 seconds
which means that it went up straight up
about 240 to 250 feet if you drop a
GoPro from about 250 feet up it will die
let's do it again man I'm so bummed I
forgot the one wheel today it's perfect
for this we do one more art to cross the
field shower and go over the trees
hopefully that look really cool right
here
yep three two one
I didn't even see it I think I sign
let's got dirt on the front smacked into
a dirt man still rolling though alright
sweet so far so good the GoPro is still
rolling when I picked it up so now we
can do the most dangerous shot of them
all a straight up shot wren brought a
baseball glove he something to try to
catch it and keep it from breaking I
hope it works
me too good dilemma baby died I will do
my best but I make no promises good luck
red
[Music]
it's buried just completely it's still
rolling oh man this looks like the hall
that quick what's that shot is that
doing like some crazy distance test I
want you to fire it directly at me so
you want me to shoot a cannon at you yes
with a large heavy projectile that's a
good time Dart yes okay let's do
further back trust me ready three two
one
I told you to go further back haven't
way over my head
rend your blatant disregard for the
safety of my camera oh so now we're
gonna go back to the studio and we are
going to add counter rotation to all the
shots you guys want to see it stabilized
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so this is the GoPro that we shot out on
Monday and it doesn't work anymore it
still turns on but it doesn't really
work so we don't have any need for it so
that actually might be fun to do a
little bit of a giveaway here so if you
leave a comment below telling us what
you want us to put a GoPro on next we
will pick one person at random and we
will send them this GoPro so leave a
comment tell us what you want to see do
you want broken GoPro will sign it we'll
make it extra cool we'll sign it yeah I
guess some silver sharpies yeah so
thanks for watching guys if you're not
subscribed consider subscribing it's
really cool we make a lot of good stuff
woo